-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Now, guys, one of the biggest
video games out
right now is "Super Mario Bros.
Wonder."
Everybody is talking about this.
It is the hottest new game.
It's going to be during all
the holidays. It's fantastic.
I thought it'd be fun to go
head-to-head against
Tariq Trotter
in an online friend race
to see who the
"Super Mario Bros. Wonder"
champ is once and for all.
Alright?
Now, before --
Before we start, let's up
the ante a little bit, okay?
[ Power-up sound plays ]
Now, if I win the race,
everyone on the Mario side
of the audience,
the red side, will go home
with a copy of
"Super Mario Bros. Wonder"
and a brand-new
Nintendo Switch OLED.
[ Cheers and applause ]
OLED model.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Everyone else will go home
empty-handed.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, let's play the game.
If Tariq wins,
everyone on the Yoshi side,
the green side, gets the prize.
-Two. You get two.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You all have --
[ Crowd booing each other ]
-You all have red and green --
[ Crowd chanting "Jimmy" ]
You all have red and green
bandanas under your seat.
You can grab them.
You can wave them around.
Let's see the bandanas.
That's how you --
Yeah. Then you can
just show your love.
Yeah. Swing them around.
Alright, you got it.
Yeah, it's getting
rowdy out there.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It's getting rowdy
out there tonight.
-Whoo! Come on, come on!
[ Crowd cheering ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah! Alright. Alright.
Here we go.
Alright.
-Whoo!
-Alright, here we go.
Get ready for the race.
I'm going to be -- I'm Mario.
Tariq, you are Yoshi.
First one to the flag wins.
I am Elephant Mario here.
♪♪
[ Crowd cheering ]
I got to take an elephant fruit.
Oh! I got the Wonder Seed!
♪♪
-Did you get the Wonder Seed,
dude?
-I thought I did.
-Did you get the Wonder Seed?
-Yeah, yeah, I got it.
♪♪
-Come on, come on!
[ Both laugh ]
-Come on!
Ohh!
-[ Screaming ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, well, well.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo!
♪♪
I want to say
thank you very much.
Mario won.
We won fair and square.
Everyone on the Mario side
will be going home
with "Super Mario Bros. Wonder"
and a Nintendo Switch
OLED model right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But you know what? We're here
at the Tonight Show. Come on.
Everybody is going home with
a Nintendo Switch...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Super Mario Bros. Wonder" and
a Nintendo Switch OLED model!
Our thanks to the geniuses at
Nintendo.
"Super Mario Bros. Wonder"
is available now
on Nintendo Switch.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Yeah!